repartira pas rendez vous ici composeur
et le bourgeon et les masses on est
censé leur trouver comment mon fils ma
fille aînée lui comme celle ci aussi ses
petites gros de nouveaux noeuds et la
première peau de sa première mue ils
étaient robustes pour une larme
et tenez beaucoup de sa mère ans d
histoire on en a marqué le temps mais
les faits ils me l'ont pris alors je le
dépossède à mon tour c'est le protocole
classique ce soir votre bourgeon vint
clore ici et quand un bouchon s'ouvre
dans l'obscurité
il appartient à l'obscurité et je
détruirai la forêt en me servant de ce
qu'il est supposé la sauver désolé de
faire de la peine mais c'est pas ce qui
est écrit dans le car scolaire qui est
écrit dans la partie que je détiens trou